here's the question that changed my
marriage how do me and my wife want our
home to feel like when we walk in the
front
door for her here's a couple of things
that she asked me to do through tears we
live way out in the country she said
when you get home before me and it's
dark will you turn the porch lights on
so I can see it for we have like a mile
long driveway or a quarter mile long
driveway can you turn the porch lights
on it makes me feel like the home is
well our house is welcoming me home will
you clean up all these piles everywhere
cuz I walk home and there's piles
everywhere and I inhale real sharply
versus exhaling and dropping my
shoulders now a clean house isn't a mom
scolding a little boy for me a clean
house is me telling my wife I love you